welcome back to Las Vegas now you know
you can't do Labor Day Without Good Eats
so our manchini of neon Feast is here to
talk what's on the food menu and what's
in the food news welcome back Al good to
be back thanks for having me of course
so what is the latest there's all kinds
of stuff going on um as always yeah
congrats to my friends of the golden
Tiki which is one of the coolest tiki
bars you'll ever see anywhere they just
turned um seven years old over on Spring
Mountain Road they had a huge party a
week-long celebration unveiled a lot of
new shrunken heads I have my own trunk
and head over there by the way which is
really cool
um but they built the world's largest
Mai Tai 100 gallons they're just a big
party and it's a good excuse to get back
over there a lot of pop-ups going on
right now the voltaggio brothers are
over at Bellagio at Harvest this is
their third pop-up at Bellagio and
harvest so I'm wondering when they're
going to make it permanent yeah and it's
a lot of fun um you know they they're in
there cooking new stuff celebrity chefs
that's a great room because it has this
glass enclosed Kitchen where you can
actually go and watch the chefs work so
I like that another pop-up at Vegas Test
Kitchen or the folks from Yukon Pizza
yeah so Yukon Pizza is a great story
coming out of the pandemic this was a
guy in the film industry he was a
cameraman and he didn't have any work he
always liked to make pizza at home and
he started making them in his backyard
during the pandemic then he moved to
Vegas Test Kitchen now they've got a
brick and mortar coming up in the hunt
Ridge Shopping Center and this weekend
is the second pop-up at Vegas Test
Kitchen where they're going to be
working out new dishes so they're doing
sandwiches and meatballs all kinds of
crazy stuff and that's this is all the
stuff they're planning for their new
restaurant so that's going on we have a
new bagel shop coming up it opens on
Tuesday in Henderson Bodega Bagel which
is going to be fantastic and if you want
to wait till the end of the month we
have Sean McLean celebrity chef coming
to the Sahara so that's really cool he
has Bala so Italian Soul okay okay and
before before we end this I want to ask
you know Labor Day holidays best
barbecue go neon Feast app we have 10
places for barbecue on there so please
check out the app download it um some of
my favorites I like Soul belly barbecue
in the arts district it's amazing I'm
cool Speak Easy I'm not speakies excuse
me hockey time Vibe live music I love
big beast Texas barbecue they do very
good Texas style and I like rolling
smoke who does kind of an Arkansas style
barbecue nice see we got it all for you
here in Las Vegas thank you so much Al
thanks for having good to have you back
check out the neon Feast app JC I'll
send it over to you